voilà donc il ya eu la chanson il ya le
cinéma et fait quelques jolis rôles au
cinéma dans les ripoux norma zèle top 2
de berry et puis alors les boîtes à un
moment où vous aviez dans le monde
vingt-et-une boîte et les 21 régine dans
le monde ce qui est assez extraordinaire
confié pour gérer ça sérieusement
c'était des licences
ah ouais je faisais comme les couturiers
ah oui je les différents manger exporter
de la nuit qui est une chose mythique
plus alors en 93 ça commence à mal
tourner et vous essayez d'acheter le
palace vous l'achetez d'ailleurs et puis
une décision administrative pour une
histoire de drogue qui fait que le
palace est fermé et ça vous met dans les
difficultés financières évidemment est
plus rentable puisque vous aviez des
emprunts à rembourser j'imagine pour 5
ecstasy faits qui m'ont trouvé au kit
kat tous ces petits de 4
c'était l'ancien privilège c'est le sous
sol anglais g7 après que le plat soit
fermé disons que après 7,7 prise
extraordinaire de ce concours mais ce
gros coup une juge a décidé de fermer
trois mois le palace à n'était jamais
arrivé avant qu'ils ont saisi 5 kit kat
à la boîte l'ecstasy
aujourd'hui ben comme vous vite chez
vous basse et plus chez vous votre
appartement votre boîte chez régine vous
appartient plus haut et de ponthieu jean
marie c'est plus au moins six ans marié
toujours mon mari à 6,7 et garder ça
fait attendre amélioré des 35 ans et mon
mari c'est peut-être des petites choses
à côté et c'est pas bon c'est pas un
problème
vous croyez projet non je pense que
c'est jean-marie maniaque
alors ça jusqu'à trois fois les dents
par jour c'est alors moi c'est pas
n'importe qui régine aujourd'hui c'est
un peu ma mère quand même non pas
vraiment vous avez jusque là